tell you like think about what Elon is
doing right now a musk
I said I believe Twitter is going to be
a trillion dollar company six months ago
can I made a video about it I said if
this guy buys it it's going to be a
trillion dollar company in no time three
to five years it's a trillion out of him
you're out of your mind Scott Galloway
he'll never even buy his [ __ ] in you
guys you think he's gonna buy it he's
just Faking It you guys are idiots
Galloway Professor Galloway yeah my wife
got her MBA at NYU and that guy's so
[ __ ] annoying there's some things he
says that's good there's some things he
says you're like what are you talking
about
by the way you know this guy do you know
this Galloway guy he's got Galloway no
no he's not talking about Galloway he
was by the way in that world he's a god
well he did right that that um that
paper about how boys and men and all
this stuff yeah make money be in shape
and have sex yeah and then he got like
[ __ ] on for it I think and then he like
apologized on his podcast
he's like a Michael Porter guy yeah NYU
kind of like I don't know what you would
call that the uh what is it Collegiate
intellectual sphere I think he is you
know he had a show on CNN plus they
crushed it it's I don't know if you
heard about it yeah yeah it blew up so
yeah so but anyways you look at Elon
Elon is not chasing money elon's like I
think I can take Twitter to a billion
active users dude if you take Twitter to
a billion active users 10 pay eight
bucks a month that's 800 million dollars
a month in Revenue that's 10 billion a
year in Revenue yeah bro you don't need
any advertisement you tell everybody
screw off I don't need any of this stuff
then all of a sudden it's a trillion
dollars so so the solution his his uh
method of doing it that works so well he
solves for what is my solution how
difference is going to be he goes and
gathers Intel from everybody he doesn't
come up with all the ideas what do you
think what do you think think and then
all of a sudden he's Rich so but if you
if you flip it and it's only the money
you're chasing you will slow down can I
ask you guys a question do you guys
think angel I'm going to ask all you
guys do you guys think his motive for
the Twitter takeover was genuinely him
going people we can't even talk was he a
savior for free speech obviously the
money's involved but what do you think
his General like I I think genuinely
like I'm a Christian I believe in God
I'm not overly religious but dude
sometimes God just plucks in these
little people because if it's not for
him you see how what it is in China
about regular Americans don't understand
they don't watch what's happening I know
they're beating the [ __ ] out of these
people they're all they have drones
spraying chemicals and [ __ ] on them
they're they are it's horrible over
there it's slowly this bind you you see
what they have with the seat they're
they're kovid lockdown [ __ ] this
contract field would gladly love not to
go that extreme but they would love to
keep us locked down make us just
depending on the government do you guys
think that that's what his motive like
Elon [ __ ] is that he genuinely gives a
[ __ ] about us us and Free Speech I think
so I think it's it's definitely part of
it I don't know what percentage but I
think I think it's also like like buying
a Rolex of retail where he's like even
if you hate it it's not going down yeah
you know yeah so it's like I can't
you're not gonna lose money on Twitter
if you can figure out spaceships he can
figure out [ __ ] Twitter yeah yeah
let's be honest yeah it's not like the
hardest thing it's like you have the app
where everybody talks that's where all
the news comes out this is the news he
bought the news yeah so uh yeah I think
he'll figure it out and I think the more
active users the more money it's going
to generate even if he's not charging a
monthly subscription it's like you want
to be on the platform that everybody's
on yeah do you guys think you guys think
the government is going to get involved
because I know the yeah the White House
was like oh we're looking at it closely
oh not because it's somebody that wants
free speech now you guys are all of a
sudden worried about it they can only
play these games for 18 months before
DeSantis gets you think
yours age you're
so with all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks right
here future looks bright here we got
them in white we got them in Black we
got them in red or black on black sold
out these are about to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he bought three
then when those three people wore it in
the office they had to order 58 of them
because people wanted the future looks
bright hat especially during times like
this because ain't nobody saying future
looks bad toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]